the following is a presentation of the
st louis chess club
[Music]
welcome everybody this is round three of
the 2022 spring chess classic i am grand
master alejandra ramirez here with my
good friend grandmaster christian
kirilla to bring you all the action of
the day alejandro always a pleasure to
be here doing commentary in this
beautiful studio absolutely and we have
a great tournament for you it is of
course a not the sink field cup it's not
the us champ but it is a couple of
amazing round robin stepping stones for
collegiate and young players to go
right into the elite and we have a
star-studded field we have how many
world championships do we have in this
tournament i didn't count them alejandro
by surprise but we have a lot of them i
know one of your students is a world
champion darius virg who is uh 26 2670
one of the highest rated players in the
event and one of your students is a
world champion in michonne
that is true alejandro you see you
caught me by surprise yes we have at
least two junior world championships
jeffreys as well imagine wow let's take
a look at the standings right now in
group a as we are talking about this
star-studded field speaking of him
jeffrey chung is currently the leader of
group a after winning his first two
games defeating his competitor darius
spirits in their matchup yesterday ray
robson and araka kobian also won their
games yesterday reaching one and a half
points meanwhile sam savion ilya nishnik
and hans demon all have
two draws and are now on 50 and tied for
the seventh position we have darius virg
who lost yesterday mikhail on tip of
alex lenderman and camille dragoon let's
take a look at the standings of group b
where we also have only one player with
two points and that is chris recka
starting the tournament quite strong he
is followed closely by christopher you
and assam hanin with one and a half
points each meanwhile robert hungaski
al-shamri jj alimorandi and titus
stramavichus all with fifty percent and
tied for eighth place we have abhimanyu
misra the youngest grand master in the
world at only 12 years and i believe 10
months armand mikhailian also with half
a point and in last place harshid raja
with no points yes and the tournament
format for
this event we have two 10 player round
robins the time control is of 90 minutes
for 40 moves with a 30 second increment
from move one and of course you get
those extra 30 minutes on move 40.
also players are not allowed to mutually
agree to a draw in less than 40 moves
they can repeat the position they can
give perpetual checks but they cannot
mutually agree to a draw this is going
to guarantee a very combative tournament
and let's look at the schedule alejandro
nine rounds of chess played in
consecutive days no rest here at all of
every single round starts at 1 pm except
for thursday march 10th that is to give
enough time for playoffs if necessary if
players are tied for first place they
will be playing it off over the board
for the top prize the round starts at
1pm but we start the commentary at 3 30
p.m central time every single day except
the last one when we will be starting at
1 30 p.m yes and
join us here in the conversation on
social media we have uh
spring chess classes you can follow us
at us chess champs and if you are
following us right now on twitch for
every 75 dollars that we erase that will
be on subs bits donations or any other
method
we will be able to give one child chess
programming for the entire semester
that's going to sponsor
one child to be able to get chess
education here at the st louis chess
club certainly a worthy cause you are
potentially helping build the foundation
of a future world champion that's right
so please join us in that endeavor as we
take a look at the pairings for group a
we have hans demon playing against sam
savion alex slenderman is going to be
playing against ilya nishnik those two
were teammates over at webster
university
meanwhile camille dragoon who currently
plays for university of texas at rio
grande valley will be playing against
webster alum ray robson misha antipov uh
here in the battle of collegiate chess
representing university of missouri will
be playing against darius schwertz
playing for saint louis university and
the current leader jeffrey xiong is
certainly going to be having the matchup
of the day against aram hakobian who
currently attends webster university one
of the rising talents here in st louis
you can see him there sporting that
webster gorlock blue he's had a very
good year in the pa in the past year
really increasing his level haram is a
much improved player from when he came
here for a classic
a couple of a few years ago he actually
played this in the b group and he has
upgraded not only to the a group but
currently have a point behind the leader
let's take a look at the b group as we
have the matchups of iron mikhailian
against christopher you elsa maria de
body in uh i will be playing against
robert hongoski dynasty will be playing
against jj ali morandi another
collegiate battle in that one abimanu
mishra the youngest master in history is
going to be playing against harsha
harshid raja and chris repka with two
points out of two will try to continue
his strong showing here in the spring
classic 2022 against sam hanin who
started also with a good one and a half
point start but certainly chris with a
perfect score so far and with the white
pieces is going to try to increase that
amount of points christian what can you
tell us about the game of your student
well speaking about that very key
matchup in the big group between chris
rappa and hassan cunning we have a very
very intriguing opening leading to a
super complicated position let's go uh
get through the game knight to f3 d5
chris rapco starts with this ready setup
he's going to go g3 bishop g2 castle and
uh try to play like this position this
bishop this fianchetto bishop on the
long diagonal very important piece for
white bishop to g7 and we've seen this
quite a few times in this tournament
already white generally plays the move
d4 and stops black from taking full
control of the center with the move e5
that's why black usually doesn't go
knight to f6 but starts with g6 and
bishop to g7 so that this diagonal is
open and now we'll be able to build up
and threaten this move e5 well chris
repka says i don't care about your e5
take the center i'm going to just simply
castle put my king to safety and i'm
going to allow you to take full control
of the center now white uh has to figure
out how to attack uh these two pawns
either at the pawn on e5 with the move
d4 either the pawn on d5 with the move
c4 or e4 of course neither of those
right now works so you have to prepare
those with a move d3
knight to e7 c4 immediately uh tackling
this pawn on d5 potentially uh
threatening the transition into some
sort of a uh sicilian almost almost a
reversed dragon sicilian with this pawn
on g6 and the [ __ ] pawn g7 d takes c4
they take c4 now
if black decides to exchange the queens
white is going to have a very
comfortable advantage in uh the end game
for example if you do this i will simply
take and after um castle i'm simply
going to develop my knight to c3 and now
you have a very difficult choice to make
because i have a big threat and that is
potentially to go knight to b5 so for
example if you uh continue developing
naturally i'm just simply going to go
knight to b5 and now you have huge
problems defending the pawn on c7 this
position is already quite difficult and
if you try uh to play the move c6 and
say okay this c6 is a very
good move because it stops the bishop's
action on the long diagonal at the same
time it controls these very important
key squares for the knight d5 and b5 but
right now you're allowing me to get to
d6 so i'm going to transition
that knight to d6 which is going to lead
to a very very pleasant position for
white
black decided not to exchange the queens
after
after uh taking on c4 he decided to go
castle get ready to take on d8 in case
white decides to exchange the queens
with his rook knight to c6 knight to d5
and now we see once again a structural
transition after this move knight to d4
bishop takes d4 e takes d4 it looks kind
of odd from white's perspective because
you gave away a very good bishop for a
knight
also you're going to help elongate the
action of the bishop on g7
h3 bishop to c8 rook to e1 c6 knight to
f4 but you do have um some problems with
this pawn on d4 also you open the avenue
for this pawn on the e file to
potentially go down the board to e5 and
then e6
let's see what happened keep that in
mind keep that idea in mind a5 e5 c5 e6
immediately
attacking the blacking and potentially
opening up the e file now this is
already trouble for black we have this
position on the board right now
and it feels to be honest from well
first of all the computer is saying that
white is completely crushing at this
point but also from a practical
perspective it just simply feels like
black is suffocating at this point i
really like what chris wrapkin is doing
in this one and with a victory let's not
forget he will be moving on to three out
of three points that's an incredible
start for him and it's not just the
three out of three i felt it he's played
a really good chance i felt that he's
taken his chances and he's been
relatively precise perhaps that moment
against raja in the game two who didn't
feel it was 100 but he really took that
advantage from the beginning to the end
and i've been very impressed with his
play here at the spring classic 2022.
let's go to the other key match-up of
the day as we do have the game of
jeffrey xiong and aram jacobian let me
take you to what i think is the critical
moment of the position
here after
a lot of theory and some wild
complications we got to this position
where jeffrey has a couple of key
choices let me put you more or less on
what's going on here
you see there's a lot of tension let's
count the pieces first both sides have
all of them but some pawns are missing
for black white is currently up a pawn
but is faced with the thread of this
bishop on f8 it just came from g7 to f8
targeting this rook on v4 so there are
some complications here on the queen
side there's a lot of tension going on
on the
left side of the board
and
he had at this point jeffrey two choices
you could take on b5 i think this is the
simpler option however black has a
couple of options that make white's
conversion task very difficult even the
move queen c8 is possible but i think
even bishop takes b5
kind of works tactically the point being
that rook takes b5 pawn takes d4 the
knight on c3
is actually the only defender of
this
rook on b5 so it cannot it cannot move
and i'll take on c3 later which means
that i have this four versus three i
might be down upon in some variations
but conversion is going to be very very
far from simple that being said
i think that was a much better option
than what happened here bishop f8 he
took with the knight on b5 and went for
these complications knight takes b5
bishop takes b4 you really have to take
on a7 you need to get your exchange back
the move bishop takes before simply
allows bishop takes b5 and there's no
trickery
knight takes a7 uh bishop takes d2 rook
takes d2 queen takes a4 and d5 and
perhaps jeffrey calculated all the way
down to this position and thought
well my position looks super nice my
knight on a7 is stranded but because of
my last move d5 i'm going to be able to
put it on c6 i have protected pass pawn
on the d5 square but a cold shower came
in the game as around
uncork to move bishop takes d5 a
desperado tactic that means that you
actually give up the bishop for a pawn
before giving it up for free notice that
you cannot take on a7 or at least not
successfully because i just captured the
bishop back and white is thrilled with
this exchange he remains uh with an
extra pawn on d5 that's protected and
passed but after bishop takes d5 the
structure actually collapses and notice
that this knight is still stranded the
best that he could do was play the move
knight c8 it doesn't really matter if he
takes on d5 or uh plays knight c8 we'll
get to a very similar structure after
the move queen a6 which is ultra precise
uh the idea is that knight d6 is not on
tap anymore this is a very very good
move the queen is covering that square
and after knight e7 check there's really
nothing better rook takes pawn takes e4
d6 rook e6 queen d1 we have the current
position in which material is even you
can count it out but it feels so much
more pleasant to be black now we see
that pawn coming uh liking the game
between chris uh rebecca and uh sam khan
yeah all the way to e3 yeah and it has
to be captured there's no real choice
capture has it has happened and you
don't have to capture immediately you
could even consider something like queen
b6 but the point is that when this pawn
eventually disappears this one's really
not going anywhere and this king on g1
it's a little bit weak on the dark
squares notice that this is a light
square bishop black has two knights and
in
just by the way the chess works that
means your dark squares are relatively
undefended and this diagonal strikes me
as a little bit of a problem eventually
i'm not saying that black has a clear
advantage or anything like that but if i
had to pick any side it would certainly
be black and i think jeffrey is the one
that has to be very precise to equalize
this end game and also i think another
critical point is that that knight on h4
despite the fact that there's no more
pawn on e4 restricting his movement back
to f3 you can still not put the knight
on f3 because that's going to allow me
my knight to jump to e4
and that might be a huge problem coupled
with the fact that you also have this
weakness on the a7 g1 diagonal and uh
after the removal of the e3 pawn well
that's going to be a huge problem
jeffrey might be in trouble alejandro
what do you know i i agree with that
completely
before we delve too much into it let's
go uh to see the price fun of this
tournament and see what the players are
participating for it's not just
experience and it's not just for fun it
is a serious amount of money here
yeah six thousand dollars for first
place four thousand per second and three
thousand per third uh prices are split
up if players end up with the same
amount of points except for first place
remember that there will be a playoff
for that position in the b group it's a
slightly smaller um
price fund but of course they are
slightly lower rated four thousand
dollars for first place still very good
2500 for second and two thousand for
third
uh let's just go through the horn real
around the whole real quick uh and
i have a feeling that some of the games
are going to finish quite quickly so
let's go to those before they end up as
we do have the game between hans niemann
and sam sevien on the screen it we're
not going to go through the whole thing
it was a very deeply theoretical open
relopez which has been all of the rage
in the last few years and it didn't seem
like hans put any real pressure on
salmon and it's true that he's currently
up upon but as you see this pawn on e5
is absolutely stuck it's already
attacked by both rooks i don't see even
the slightest is there a plan even a way
to try at least to uh win this game
potentially get the king to f4 no you
you do you whenever you go king g3 i go
king d5 yeah
you actually make zero progress and i'm
not really sure why sam is taking such a
long time here to think but nobody
is rushing him he has plenty of time to
figure out this draw a very solid
preparation by
uh the player that tied for first in the
us championship let's not forget that he
had an amazing performance there
actually played the playoff against
wesley so and fabiano carrana didn't
come ahead in those games but still
reaching such a position is just an
incredible achievement it's been a great
year for sam also for hans as well yeah
beginning of last year
in 2021 i think he was around 25 20.
and then he went to europe and he
started playing tournament after
tournament and now he is like 26.50 and
not stopping yeah this is a clash
between two emerging superstars of
american chess yeah and seven also give
him a lot of credit that he was stuck
for a very long time in this range of
2640 to 2660. he had achieved that at a
very young age but it seemed like he
wasn't making any progress and recently
he had a couple of breakthrough
tournaments he had the u.s championship
he had that grand prix in riga where he
also did rather well and he has reached
26.84 uh certainly a milestone in his
career and is looking forward to
breaking that magical 2700 barrier
absolutely and we see him play rook to
b5 this waiting game you absolutely have
no way to make any progress as white the
players i would assume after king to g3
if sam responds instantaneously with
king to g5 they will find the repetition
and the game might be over in the next
couple of minutes yeah and worry not
that if he doesn't play the move king g5
they will also draw he immediately plays
with yes
and this is going through the motions
probably and we're going to see some
rookie 1 group a5 rookie 2 rook b5
they're professionals they find a way
they will find a way absolutely we can
move out of this one there's really
nothing interesting to
to see here uh let's finish up the a
group as we have the other games going
on alex london playing against ilya
nishnik i just want to put on the
positions very quickly assess them and
move on uh in this one it seems pretty
clear that it's alex slenderman that is
on the back foot you can see that this
knight on c3 is a bit of a monster i
don't know if it's going to be enough to
win the game but
this knight on c3 is
it caused my attention and uh alex seems
to be on the defensive side and let's
not forget these two players know each
other very very well they are former
teammates at western university i
believe both of them graduated recently
but they have been roommates they know
each other very very well they've
analyzed chess together so they know
their strengths and weaknesses
absolutely
speaking of other collegiate players or
former collegiate players in ray robson
uh graduating also from webster playing
against current utrgv university of
texas rio grande valley student camille
dragoon this one i don't have an engine
on it it was kind of a mess i don't know
how to assess this one so quickly cons
are equal we're gonna call it equal
that's the lazy way to do it right i
like it uh white has bishops that's
always nice but this knight on h2 is
kind of garbage and i'm always worried
about f4 coming in dynamic equality and
we'll move on
uh jeffrey shum we all we already looked
at we don't like his position and in the
battle of our students of misha antipov
andario schwarz
this one
it also looks more or less equal
it looks equal but i have to say
from a couple of moves ago i feel like
black has made tremendous progress it
does feel like that right this bishop of
b6 is quite nicely anchored the knight
has returned to f5 where it pressures d4
unfortunately it always feels like i'm
going to be missing a break i feel that
if this bonds if this bond was an f pawn
and i got f6 in
i could definitely think of an advantage
for black but as long as d4 remains
remains defended i i really don't see a
way through and i think critically in
this matchup is how they're doing on
time because both of them are sort of
time trouble addicts oh yeah they're the
slowest players ever misha antipov with
21 minutes and darius with 18 with only
11 years ago now they'll be fine i think
they'll be okay and it's also depending
on the dynamics of the position this one
doesn't have that much that many
dynamics there's not that much to
calculate you play a lot you can play a
lot of moves by feel without uh doing
anything egregious and here as we
expected hans niemann has drawn his game
against sam sebian
uh all right let's take a look at group
b in that case
uh we have here iron man michaelian
against christopher u
we do count the pawns yet again and
christopher is up one pawn down one pawn
oh sorry christopher is black yeah
christopher is down one pawn but he is
pretty active
i do like the rook on c2 i just don't
think that's enough to compensate for a
pawn
this one seems more like
black is going to probably hold but will
suffer a lot
um
specifically because that bishop on f1
which protects the
critical square g2 yeah you're always
looking to trick white something like
rook d2 or take c2 but as long as this
bishop stays on f1 it liberates the rest
of the army in this case it's the rooks
except the rook on b1 because if you
leave the first rank then i'm going to
be able to pin you on the first rank so
you have to be
careful with the record b1 but the rook
on c5 is free to roam anywhere she wants
yeah rook a5 might be
coming you never know maybe you throw in
c4 just to have the pawn defended you
throw in c4 you play rook a5 you start
attacking this pawn on
a7 and you start asking questions that
might not be so easily answered
definitely a wide advantage don't no no
not really sure if it's enough here i
think rook a5 is an automatic where you
defend this pawn and
attack the one on a7
white's better i'm not sure if it's
enough
let's go to the game of el shan maria de
body against robert hungaski
and this is a mess some kind of king's
indian structure
it's a complete mess right this nano c6
is really nice
but
i also wonder if it's doing anything
it's not but
it's preventing black from at least at
the moment doubling up on the g-files
that creates a very unpleasant fork
but for example what if you just simply
go rook to g7 to prepare that i was
actually wondering if on rook g7
i'm kind of happy to play the move
knight d8 98 right and i'll go to e6 and
perhaps for this reason it's that we see
robert playing actually the move
knight g5 it also covers the e6 square
the knight wasn't doing much on h7 to
begin with
uh i don't quite see what the follow-up
is is there any world
where we're considering
yeah taking on f3
absolutely at some point potentially but
i think it's uh critical that i double
up on the g file because that's going to
allow me to uh have sort a lot of
threats checkmating on the g file yeah i
completely agree with you you do it
patiently the knight on g5 is fine you
don't have to take on f3 next move i'm
eyeing the possibility i don't like rook
g7 as much because of knight d8 maybe we
play your idea but with rook f7
and then rook g7 this way the knight
doesn't have that many squares to go to
uh
i don't
see why it's planned though
so just so people understand what i'm
talking about when i'm seeing some
checkmating threats let's make some
random moves let's go knight to a5 just
because you were asking me what the
progress potentially could be for black
knight to a5 rook to c6 to start
attacking some pawns that could be an
idea
and i do need your rook to get off the
first round
you need my help right i need your help
a little bit okay let's just do this so
c6 and now i'm going to take with the h
knight on f3 you're going to take back
yes and i here i can go knight to h3
yeah here we understand that this is
winning but knight h3 is even nicer
rook to f1
it seems like you're defending oh wait
never mind you are defensive
no but
knight f3 is actually crashing in this
position that is true so yeah it does
tether the rook to the first strike
which is actually important right is if
i can double up on the g file and this
tethers this rook to the defense of g1
i can at least claim i've made a little
bit of progress and at some point i'll
hint that those knight takes f3 knight
takes c4 will give me enough positional
compensation that this knight is still
far away from the action and then my
pawns will roll but it's still very
theoretical i'd rather be black
it's not easy to break for any of the
sides but i feel like black has
um the more dynamic
yeah uh in his pieces i have to agree
completely uh chris repcka
wow this move rook h6 screams ugly but
perhaps there was no choice
yeah this looks like it's almost over
yeah this looks it just it just looks
like chris is one good move away from
winning
so sorry i'm also wondering why can't i
just play knight right yeah yeah yeah
i need to get rid of the knight the
knight is a very good blockading piece
yeah and i am threatening queen g5 queen
f6 yeah this is just devastating i can't
i can't allow you to do that devastating
consequences for sure so how are you
going to defend against that i think i
have to take it and then install
something else on e7 i'm not really sure
what and the question is what do i take
back with do i take back with the pawn
and connect my pawns or do i take with a
rook get a tempo try to get a tempo in
let's stick with the rook i like
thinking with the rear queen e7 and
maybe just queen f4 honestly yeah i
don't think you ever can take this pawn
there will always be a pen on the e file
that will pick up the bishop and i feel
that queen b8 is a threat queen e5 isn't
that i mean there it is
d6 is on tap yeah this one is not
looking good for black surprisingly uh
chris doesn't do that he goes knight d
knight h3 which actually has a very not
subtle but very strong idea of knight g5
and knight f7 that also looks completely
devastating um thank you for putting
your rook on h6 right yeah and not to
mention that i think queen f4 is a
threat
because they don't have rook takes f5
yeah well actually rook takes a five you
can take back with the knight and the
reminder doesn't work
but
is so deadly because you don't have a
minor piece to defend that f7 square you
would love to get your bishop to e8 but
that's just simply impossible no i i i
think your student is cruising towards a
win in this one another nice game by
replica three in a row and in style not
just by luck absolutely
and another critical match that i think
we should be
having our eyes on is that one
this one between titus ramavichis and jj
alimorandi who plays very a very crazy
brand of chess
uh currently he is down the exchanges
black he does have a pawn for it
and what worries me more than the
material balance is that he is pretty
tied up you see these powerful rooks
are doing a good job of controlling on
the files especially on b7 and this 9 on
a6 perhaps are not attacking that much
but are definitely controlling that rook
on d8 i'm not sure
how decisive white's advantage is
but i wouldn't be surprised it's
actually just winning
and you were mentioning uh black's
pieces being tied up we see uh the
bishop and the knight on a6 on the rim
it doesn't feel like they're very strong
piece pieces but actually they control
the rook perfectly the rook doesn't have
any good moves on the eighth rank you
would love to put it on b8 or a8 and
start attacking my pawn on a3 but
unfortunately that's just simply
impossible to do at this point yeah i
think if black had some kind of activity
you wouldn't really be thinking that
black is doing so badly especially with
a powerful pawn on c4 but i it is the
fact that he is completely tied down you
can see this monster bishop
make sure that this knight on f6 doesn't
join the fray controls d5
knight c7 is always kind of an issue
here for uh the black side he has played
the move bishop f5 i have the feeling
that titus is a few moves away from
winning this game so he's looking to put
uh the bishop on d3 yeah the only
unfortunate thing is that even when you
get here you always have to be worried
about
yeah
that being said
i don't know i don't think i should be
allowing bishop d3 so let's make some uh
well let's improve our position rook to
d6 i love rook d6 it's the first
instinct in the position maybe rook d4
also because you are after all attacking
a pawn on c4 yeah i think rook d4 rook
d6 uh both look quite good i i actually
i'm warming up
a lot to rook d4
uh you can always try to push the pawn
on all the way to c2 but once it reaches
c2 it'll probably get captured you
always have knight before you always
have rook c2 you always have rook c1 you
don't really have the activity to defend
that pawn
um
maybe i'm forced to play b5 but then
after knight c7 i start shedding
material it feels like c3 has to be the
critical choice for black
at this point try to put the pawn on c2
and
i'm assuming that's why he played the
move bishop to f5 to control that square
c2 right
yeah here though f3 i feel like
you're actually with the idea of g4
maybe g4 it makes the bishop choose
yeah it makes the bishop choose whether
you want to go into this diagonal you
don't have access to the defense of c2
anymore so this bundle c3 is bye-bye and
if you go to g6 then you're going to
start running into issues on undefended
pieces i like that move i think f3 is
good it also gives a loft always super
useful
for the king yeah this looks this looks
like it's close to winning for the white
side and the only game we haven't really
looked at is uh the game between
abimanu mishra of course a superstar of
the chess world
is
against raja harshit i think materials
even
but that's about the only good thing i
can say about black's position
is pawns are all discoordinated these
are all weak
whereas you can see the white house two
solid pawn islands his knight activity
is probably what's keeping him in the
game and the question is how long that's
going to last
because i start trying to exchange those
90. i wasn't sure if you start with
knight dc4 or knight ec4 but both are
extremely logical moves the point is
that if you are forced to give up this
knight i'm not and i'm not seeing a
better move
i open avenues to e4 i the knight on c4
itself is beautiful i can always install
the pawn on b3 to defend it and it gives
me access to the move queen d6 after
which
well
black is
a collection of weaknesses more than he
is opposition
yeah this this looks rather bad for
black unless he has some kind of tactic
or some way to exploit the activity of
this knight on b4 maybe with the move
queen d5
uh trying to force white to take two i'm
not going to exchange but you'll never
exchange that you'll just sidestep rook
d1 is coming also at some point maybe c3
or queen takes e4
and after queen takes c4 i am going to
be a pawn up yeah you're gonna be at
least one point up and again the knight
on c4 is not going anywhere so a couple
of moves ago it was black who was upon
up right now it seems to be white and
actually let's just go through this game
because it was quite an interesting
opening
and um fashionable one
yes i've seen it actually in the games
of some of your students alejandra so
i'm sure you know a couple of things
about this structure as well bishop to
b5 knight to d7 and this idea of a4 a6
and g6 now of course black has a lot of
options you can play the move e5 you can
play the move e6 you can also just stop
this move a5 with the move b6 black
decides to go g6 and transition uh his
bishop on g7
and after b5 a takes b5 ambassador
black decides not to capture recapture
the pawn on b6 immediately but in fact
he's going to focus his attention on
expanding on the queen side with the
move a5 and potentially threatening to
take more space now another key idea
behind this move a5 is that for example
if you take with the knight or with the
queen on b6 after knight to d2 this
knight is very close to jumping and uh
putting a plug on the whole position of
blacks on the queen side with a knight
on a5 if the knight lands on a5 your
position is going to be paralyzed
because this bishop is not going to go
to b7 you're not going to have enough
space for your pieces that's going to be
bad news for black that's why instead of
recapturing immediately black decides to
go a5 also it makes some space for the
bishop potentially go a6 e5
and we see this pawn sacrifice in the
center now what's the idea behind this
pawn sacrifice because you're not
recapturing the pawn anytime soon but
what you're doing is you're disrupting
black's pawn structure now you see how
many weaknesses we have how many islands
of pawns we have in a black's camp we
have one this pawn on a5 very weak pawn
we have two the pawn on c5 very weak
pawn as well and i have an incredible uh
square for my knight on c4 potentially
reinforced by this pawn on d3 as well as
the pawn potentially landing on b3 this
position strategically it feels like
it's very good for white so what black
has to do is find some dynamic
potentially with the move f5 but
unfortunately he was unable to find that
and we see after queen takes b6 knight
to c4 we see a couple of exchanges right
now
this pawn the first weakness has
collapsed
and now we get this position it feels
like it's just a nagging pressure
nagging strategical pressure from the
white side
and unfortunately after h4 f5 was a
little bit too much allowing
white to
place his attention on this pawn on e6
another weakness in black's camp and
after this we have this position
and we got to the point where you are
mentioning alejandro that black is in
trouble yeah absolutely it just looks
optically bad and the more i look at the
position and try to make a few moves for
the black side the more difficult it
becomes it does feel like it's very bad
speaking of very bad i also don't like a
jeffrey's handling of that tough end
game he is we said that one is a
difficult one it's a difficult one but
it feels like it's close to falling
apart at the moment he's played with
bishop f3
and he has for now the idea that if i
play
rook a1 depending on the first ring
i do have the move rook d1 so that's not
an issue and for that reason i'm
thinking why not start with the move
knight e3
control the d1 square
start hinting at the move rook a1 being
a strong threat you can see that this
king is currently in some sort of
background problems because of this
powerful knight on e3
and i am struggling to find a move here
for um
for jeffrey
his position is terrible
you want me to tell you the assessment
of the engine yeah sure
that is black is crushing crashing yeah
three point five three point five yeah
yeah your black is completely crushing
right now i don't even i just don't see
what to play here the best movie in the
position is queen to g1 good luck
finding that move queen g one i wouldn't
ever even consider this one exactly
so rookie one
and now bishop to d1 and try to hang on
like this and i mean no amount of prayer
is going to hold this position together
man bishop d1 feels like you're getting
mated on the
on this diagonal right
maybe there's nothing immediate but man
they look scary
that's key there's nothing immediate i'm
just simply going to go back with the
knight to g4
really exactly and i'm just going to tie
you up like this knight g4 here knight
g4 yeah
wow i would have
really i would have never guessed this
move yep
yeah knight to g4 then i'm going to
bring the queen to c3 i'm going to start
putting pressure on the rook on d2
that's one of your main defenders
at some point you're just simply not
going to have enough pieces to defend
the other pieces
and you don't have any counter play that
is the point the lack of counter play is
very serious and this end games are
always lost right oh yeah yeah this must
be lost yeah yeah your king is too weak
and this is key when we have
disimbalances some pieces against the
queen if the queen has targets
specifically the opposing king well the
queen in general is to be favored no for
sure i just
i'm not sure how easy it will be to win
this i do have a powerful pawn here
but yeah i i have trouble believing that
this is enough for white
yeah i have too much trouble believing
that so a great opportunity here i go f5
yeah yeah i mean i i really don't
believe it but there's not much better
here for uh jeffrey uh let's see the
time situation we only have five more
moves until time control so aram is
certainly trying to play as precisely as
possible doesn't need to rush he does
only have five minutes for those five
moves though so he needs to be
concrete
and jeffrey has 22 minutes that's one
thing about uh jeffrey he almost never
gets in time travel and he's reaching
for the knight i mean it's such a
logical move even if you don't see the
remaining of this remainder of the
sequence
93 is just such a tempting move in this
position and you defend the knight
that's immediately attacked you put it
in a better square it's on a dark square
yes going for it
the knight lands on e3 with devastating
consequences this one is really not
looking good for white unless jeffrey
manages to create enough dynamic before
time control i think this uh one is
going to go aram's way and aram is going
to be the new leader because right now i
think he's standing on one and a half
out of two with a win against jeffrey
jeffrey is on 12 of two yeah jeffrey's
on perfect score and this would leapfrog
aram to pole position and what a victory
that would be of course against the top
rated player in the event and with the
black pieces yeah yeah huge victory huge
victory here who's around has certainly
shown incredible preparation in this
tournament very strong resilience as i
said it's one of those players that has
really impressed me on the amount of
improvement
that he has achieved since joining
uh webster university here in st louis
uh
credit certainly to coach lekwang liam
over there at webster
no absolutely he came in to the united
states a couple of years ago i think he
was something along the lines of 25.50
and right now he's a very strong
contender around that 26 20 26 50
range yeah sometimes i see his games and
i'm surprised it's not even slightly
higher rated at 26.06 it feels
underrated underrated for sure yeah
all right uh let's let uh jeffrey
figure it out in that position meanwhile
the game of antipov and schwerz i don't
think we'll see too many changes before
time control the players will probably
shuffle around a little bit
it's hard to it's hard for me to figure
out a plan for either side i would
really like to play something like king
g6 h5 and 8 and g4 but i'm never able to
actually defend this pawn on g5 so h5 is
never going to be playable
uh unless
white voluntarily retreats the knight
which he did which he did
thank you misha for the
uh for throwing my explanation out the
window
and can i play h5 immediately is the
question i think he's trying to coax him
into playing h5 yeah and darius doesn't
even bother analyzing that immediately
plays the move king g6 but now h5 i feel
is a threat
i'm not really sure what it does but i
like i like the space
the more i see the move the more i
realize it doesn't do anything
i think one of the things uh that misha
is getting ready for whenever uh black
plays move h5 is to meet that with the
move g4 yeah g4 actually becomes quite
annoying and i think this is why he
played knight to h2 yeah now of course
it has ideas of potentially getting the
knight to f6 but the question is does
that work right now
so let's say knight to g4
try to place the knight to f6
the thing is that even if you reach l
i'm just going to push you there sure
and
even in positions where i
cleanly give up my exchange
oh okay
i'm not really sure that white is
better so rook to a8
yeah oh because of this point let's try
to invade yeah i'm trying to get to my
pawn just quite
but i see what you're saying
i definitely see what you're saying it
doesn't feel like
white has a clean way of breaking
through except this idea of root beer
takes b7 but even after that potentially
with the rook on b7 i'm going to just
simply put my work on the eighth rank on
f8 and how do you get the root back yeah
what we're saying is that if i just
randomly pass moves even in this
position even here after you take on b7
and i just put my rook back
this this rook might just be completely
stuck
right so 96 is actually going to
immediately
recapture it yes you can sacrifice your
rook for the bishop but then what
advantage does white have
and speaking of that knight d6 maybe i
can just play 96 even before that and
try to find a better square for my
knight yeah it feels like black is
really in not enough compensation enough
compensation not in any danger but also
not playing for a win
uh let us see what else we got um
i don't really know why how or in which
world
nishnik put the knight on c3 on a3
so everything i know about chess says
don't put the knight on a3 yeah like
knight on the rim is dim and if this
bishop comes to d3
this knight can't move but i guess it's
the specifics of the position he's
trying to play something like queen c3
the knight would be a very good uh
powerful piece if these queens get
traded but that being said uh i don't
know why i can't play bishop d3 which he
has played c3 and then just queen d1 or
queen f1 something
and right now with this knight on a3 the
bishop on d3 is just i mean just
controls the nominating the knight
i
i'm not i'm not i don't feel
that londoner can really be better in
this position but no way but this knight
on a3 is really ridiculous what is the
knight doing there well you're going to
go queen to d1 right yeah queen d1 i
think i will be able to force matters
after queen to b2 if i'm concerned at
any queen b2 yeah yeah of course queen
b2 and now you can force this queen to
e2 to defend that one on
a2 and then i can simply just go
backward to c3 yeah i could make a draw
i'm not really sure that's what i'm
looking for i could maybe
take though here and play knight c2
because you really don't want to play e4
not knight b1 knight c3
uh knight b1 knight c3 might be even
stronger although i don't know which
one's stronger because this is this
might be lost also right um i see what
you're doing yeah i'm trying to force
you to uh see the dark squares in this
position uh you don't have a dark square
defender only the pawn on e3 and since
this knight is kicking this pawn away uh
e4 and the king penetrating might be
winning that being said perhaps even
more direct is to just go knight b1
knight c3 and take this pawn because uh
this pawn on b4 does take in poisson you
can't push it twice yeah perhaps it's
still it's still nishnick because of the
specifics of the position so we do have
the queen on b2 right now
yeah and i think maybe it is a
wiser not to really bother defending the
spawn on a2 but start trying to look for
some sort of counter play
i want to get rid of this bishop from
the d file so i can play queen d4 check
the moment that you take on a2 but
surprisingly i don't have those many
great options for it i would like to put
it on e4
but this kind of allows
knight b5 my point was that queen takes
queen d4 check
and then i'm going to maybe give you
checks on the eighth rank maybe put my
queen on f6 and attack f7 maybe bishop
takes g6 will be a perpetual but you
don't start with that move you actually
start with move knight b5 well he's
getting ready to play a move and i have
a feeling bishop to e4 might
come on the board what is our time
situation two minutes for lender man 21
minutes
and
yes how many moves couple more three
moves three moves to make so it's not a
huge time pressure yeah this does play
them with bishop e4 it was my instinct
and i can see
that london is also attracted to the
move
uh as i mentioned with the knight on a3
i don't think i can take on a2 and claim
any kind of winning chances perhaps you
do have to play the move knight b5
but even after knight b5
hmm
well after knight b5 we have bishop to
hg6
right
i believe you uh if you take with the f
pawn i i understand that
if you take with the king queen to d3
and if you go knight to c3 which is the
big question
i think that's just simply going to be a
perpetual after queen to d4
yeah i don't believe in knight c3
check or you take a queen to g check and
you take here with check you always have
queen d8 when the king tries to
hide on the queen side with via
um h7 g8 and f8 this yeah your king's
not going anywhere this is a good
geometry of chess it could have made it
you can't you can try to get mated in
some kind of scenario like this but
you're not gonna be playing for a win
uh in in any of these situations so you
might as well take the draw yeah this is
actually an important resource right an
iv5 bishop takes g6
cements that draw
so let's see knight p5 is not yet on the
board bishop to e4 was played but before
that because this is probably going to
take a while um let's take a look at
what is happening in the key matchup in
the b group oh yes this one because
it seems like it's over yeah it's over
it seems like it's pretty much over look
at this rook first of all i'm an
exchanger right i mean that's enough i
managed to get an exchange i'm not 100
sure how let's see after knight to f3
trying to go to g5 or h89 to g5 and now
we see knight to c6
rook to f7
you cannot even take this pawn back
because after king takes off seven i'm
just simply going to go rook to e7 and
that's going to lead to
check mates so he cannot take that pawn
but leaving this pawn ready to promote
on the seventh rank is not a good
alternative bishop to b7 rook to d5 rook
to f8 rook to e7
this is the position four minutes for
cunning right now with eight moves to go
and i don't think you're going to
survive eight more moves at this point
no he has a little bit of counter play
because of this light square uh battery
but it the rook on d5 is doing a great
job actually let me switch to that game
so yeah we're not talking about a
different one um
yeah it feels like it's just far from
enough if you try to take this uh i
think i'm just simply going to take
taken queen to h6 yeah queen h6 i also
think queenie one was winning instead of
yes i think everything's the computer
move trying to go queen to e5 yeah you
cannot take because i'm going to
infiltrate with the queen on the seventh
yeah this one is also very yes yeah a
nice so we expect chris redka to be the
early leader with three points i might
be distancing himself from the field
quite a bit
can we take a look maybe at the
standings of group b to remember who was
chasing him because it was khanian was
one of his uh close suitors there with
one he was on one and a half and i think
christopher you was also that's why
christopher you won his first game
against robert hungaski there we have it
and drew his second game quite
uneventfully so yes it's after
christopher you let's take a look at
that game then well christopher is now
winning that end game that's for sure he
might be losing that one because he was
upon down in that rooks and bishop end
game
uh yeah we can go to that um
and it's looking increasingly bad uh we
do have 137 there for army mikhail but
he has reached mu 40
which means that he does he gets an
extra 30 minutes he doesn't have to
worry about it
uh he has just made the move h5
relatively committal i have to say
but and this was move 41. it wasn't it
wasn't one move 40 yeah no he had time
to think about this one
okay so let's try to understand why this
move h5 if you just simply take right
because that's the pawn
yeah okay you could take rook h4
rook takes h5 to preserve the structure
but
basically that works on h5
i don't want to see that rook on h5 no
that work on h5 is so awkward so far
from the game so pontex h5 let's say
and i think rook to d3 now right you
want to exchange the active rook of
black
for one of your more passive rooks and
leave the rook passive on c7 against the
very active work on a6 that being said
i'm not
how do we evaluate something like this
right rookie five yeah rook a5 will go
king d4 you take on f5 pick up one pawn
and you're gonna definitely get the
second one we're definitely picking up
some more stuff on the king side and now
this is a very serious winning chances
oh i like this i actually like h5 a lot
the more i see it the more i like it so
let's see after rook to d3 can so let's
take on h5 rook to d3 maybe you can go
somewhere else with the rook but
actually you don't have anywhere else
yeah the problem is the rook d6 right if
you move off the
off of the file use root d6 will pick up
the bishop and if you buy the bullet and
take on c4
are you surviving probably not let's see
four rook d6 king e5
and now
maybe just rook takes h6
although this is not as bad as the other
variations
it doesn't feel
very pleasant right okay 5 is coming
and rook h5 is coming hanging on by a
thread at this point with black yeah but
uh
i mean you can't really ask for much
more than that from the position
yeah h5 right
good move by the way i like i like h5 a
lot and it if you are forced to play g5
heroes black you just say i
have a huge concession because f5 isn't
certainly undefended the rook on d3 is
always going to be
a more powerful move because once you
trade the bishop immediately targets
that pawn
and because it opens the avenue for this
rook or any rook on the sixth rank uh
towards the h6 pawn the page
is going to be a huge weakness yeah
actually
yeah i think if you're going to play
between gh and g5 you might as well you
might as well take the pawn on h5 and i
think there's an advantage
on playing g5 here
it doesn't look pretty it does not look
like a pretty defense here for
christopher you serious chances for uh
michaelian to score his first victory in
this event
absolutely
speaking of great winning chances let's
take a look if the game of titus trauma
vicious has made any progress
um
what is going on here
it feels very concrete at the moment but
i'm not entirely so sure if this was
correct so let's take a look back at how
we got here we looked at the move rook
d4 c3 and i like the move f3 in this
position i don't know what the engine
said
but uh the move
f3 was much better than rook c4 yeah
roxy4 looks a little weird to me because
i like the control the rook on d8 is not
participating in the position right now
let's control black's pieces let's take
away the uh squares from the f5 bishop
let's give myself a left
i'm not okay but this is a forcing line
right c2 he wants to trade the rooks
takes takes bishop g6 just to unpin the
knight it's a bit of a sad move but okay
black's position can't really ask for
that much
f4
okay so
i guess it prevents knight e5 that's an
important detail
knight e5 might be a threat in certain
positions because knight d3 helps this
pawn promote and of course you cannot
take it because c1 will promote as well
so you go f4 to prevent that but after
bishop d3 and rook c1
i'm wondering how clear
this endgame is after knight c5 i think
it's the oldest it's the only move i
think because otherwise notice that
knight before is a huge threat that will
attack here
so you really do have to play uh knight
c5 and the idea is that if knight b4
now you can just simply go bishop to g6
back yeah i can just go bishop g4 bishop
to e4 maybe yeah bishop e4 is actually a
better move
the point is that if you take on uh c2
then move knight b3
forces uh the rook away from the knight
and i can capture on c2 and then bishop
is always defending the knight on b3 i
don't think this quite works for white
and to the point where after bishop b4 i
don't see a good move because knight b3
is coming you might have to bail out
with like vertex c2 or something it's
clearly not what you want so critical
must be take stakes uh the idea of white
will be now to pass this pawn but
i do have this constructions with c4
that might be tough to
tough to overcome
so this really comes down to tempe right
it's a very concrete situation right
it's very concrete yeah so let's so
let's see
right
i assume this guy goes here
let's keep pushing a5 and
so the question is if not before
a6 wait but knight to c3 what do you do
after knight c3 uh
knight c3
because that's i mean i'm threatening
knight to e2 and that's a problem
that is a problem indeed take a look
that in many scenarios bishop on e4 is
still gonna is still going to catch this
pawn
and knight a2 is a problem 92 is a
problem okay maybe we were
too fast with making the moves out of
100 because i think this might be
winning for black yeah so wait what's
going on um
i'm not
i don't really like going into this if i
have to play king f2
but that's what they teach us
when we first learn start learning chess
whenever you get to the end game you
want to bring the king to the center
let's apply those principles alejandro
let's play good chess
if i played a good chance are you
playing up there
just calculate um no more commentary for
us yes uh you want to one
no i'm not i'm not lying this this looks
very unconvincing
what if i just go
here anyway okay king to d2 knight e2
that's fine and now i take on d3
take and take on c2
now i start pushing now it's time to
start my am i in the square boom boom
boom i am so a4 go king e7
um
oh you are okay
so let's not start pushing
i'm actually going to go king to d3
right this is hanging right now yes
that's fine you can take that
i just want to stop your king but do you
i'm not sure i'm not sure either c5
take on c5
you know this might be winning
definitely not convincing but definitely
not convincing right no no not even
close not even close not even close
i mean i i yeah you can go king the 8
king c7 i'm not 100 sure if this this is
any more even vantage
yeah you go here you go here or whatever
king c7 i'm starting to threaten to just
put the king here and yeah you can try
to win this
i don't i don't think so i think the
knight is enough for counter play
should be able to sacrifice itself for
the last remaining pawns with the help
of the other three
this looks very unconvincing it does
so what what are we missing rook c1
knight c5
you have to take i don't see another
move
do you take here
okay so what if i just simply go ah
night before you said bishop to e4 and i
don't have a good way to defend against
knight to b3 okay
yes i have to take on c5
this is not easy no i i feel like
i feel like white
is giving black
to control the knight let's go bishop to
b7 first
okay bishop b7 but i can start bringing
my king in as well
right and then you bring now i bring my
king can i bring my king
king to e3 and then i'll go bring my
king
that's not your king is a
pawn it's been a long day um
king to d4 yeah i liking d4 to control
followed by bishop to a6 yeah bishop a6
is a huge problem ah this might actually
just be crushing it i think so i think
once my king goes to d4 it might i like
this move bishop b7 i think it's the key
to the position it controls the knight
that's that's very good
yeah and i'm just going to go ahead and
assume 94 bishop takes is just lost
should be because
my plan is very simple as white after
that i will just free my rook from the
defense of this promotion with king
coming to d2 and then i'm just going to
push the a pawn
yeah you just do this you do this and
you actually have all the time in the
world you can actually go g3 first put
this king here
and then play with your rook
yeah this has just has to be winning so
maybe that's why we don't see that move
we actually see the move uh
bishop bishop e4 played instead
okay it has the idea i imagine of
controlling this bishop and if knight b4
you have the idea of knight c5 this just
transposes to something we didn't like
for white
and this is the reason why quickly takes
was played and then a night before and
the big difference is that
after knight c5 what is the big
difference
the big difference is that after knight
c5
wait a minute
uh
the big difference is after wrestling
all right wait come on guys we're ground
masters yeah what is the difference okay
so you can go into this thing and game
out with simon i take c29 to b3
this is the only thing i'm seeing okay
rook to b1
i should take c2 rook to b2 buddy i even
have bishop d1 i understand that 51 king
f2 and now you have to move the knight
away because i'm threatening king to e1
and then i will pick up your b6 pawn but
is that winning
oh i i don't think even if i take your
b6 pawn you should be able to defend
that right
yeah what are we missing knight c5 was
played
i don't think we're missing anything and
he played knight a2 what
what
knight a2 what if i play knight b3
rook to e1 and get the knight of c1 i
think this is his idea
starts to get scary for white no
but just a second i mean
do you have any threats right now what
if i just bring my king to e7
the other question is do you have any
threats ever
exactly like if i put my pawn on f5
which i think i do at some point
well first i have to stop you from
getting your king to e3 i think i
managed to do that but why we're being
told that chris rapcast we expected did
win his game but no my point is that
even if you get your king to e3 then
what
then at least i'm not losing
but wha
what
oh man i think uh yeah this was a
ali marandi might be back into this game
it's definitely the best position he's
had
since like move five but
he's still all right i i picked
alejandro i picked out the engine and
black is better yeah i'm not surprised
i'm not surprised at all black is better
already king to e7 yeah king to e7 you
don't have kf2 of course because
knight d3
picks up the rook
but if you go through f1
where are you headed
if you go to f1 first of all you take
that uh square away from your rook so
maybe i have ideas of knight to
no knight to b3 you still have rookie
one
okay
yeah here you still have
so he played something what did he do
even here you know you start going king
d6
and i'm not really sure
how you make progress i mean f5 f5
i understand i like this move i
understand that move it cements the
bishop right on against other every
variation that being said the more i
analyze the position the more
unnecessary by the way 20 seconds last
move before the time control for white
yeah he'll play king f1 i'm pretty sure
oh never mind no
one shows you how great commentators we
are rook to e1 rook to e1 sorry no rook
two f f-one i think i saw
uh elsa and morgan the body has drawn
his game against robert mugaski we
thought that was very unpleasant so
we'll go back to see it
um rook f1 currently on the board and
that's it right that's move uh 40. 40
decimal 40 for white but ali miranda has
a miranda has eight minutes to make his
final move before the time control and
what's what's the engine saying about
this inclusion of f5 and roof f1 it's
still just a slight advantage for uh
black
he's just going to play a slow game king
to f7 king to e6 king to d5 try to take
the center if i manage to get my king
all the way here well you can resign
right so you will have to find a way to
stop me from getting my
king all the way to the queen side
potentially meet that king in the middle
with white's king let's see if you're in
time so king to f2 king to e6
king to e3 king to d5
king to the two king to c4 yeah these
are all computer moves
oh you have to play knight c1 at this
point because king bb3 is a huge threat
and it's
oh my goodness but this is like a one
tempo type of situation because right
now if my king would be able to land on
c3 this would be game over yeah not to
mention you hung your pawn on g2 at some
point and i'm just assuming you cannot
take it because of rook g1 this looks
extremely scary for white
it came from it went from clearly
winning
clearly winning 1.6 even this one i'm
not so sure i think that rook d4 c3 the
move that we liked um f3 this was the
critical move and the engine was uh
considering the move knight to b4
against this uh pawn expansion on c2 now
for example if you go uh pawn on c2
now which one is the best piece for
black in the position the [ __ ] pawn f5
right it does everything these knights
are support for us knights they're uh um
stepping on each other's
they're not great knights i'm simply
going to go bishop to a6 followed by
bishop to d3 exchange this bishop and
that's going to uh allow me to also
capture the pawn on c2 which is going to
end the game so this idea of knight to
b4 bishop to a6 was crucial at this
point but it's not so easy to play
knight to b4 right because you want to
control the rook
you want to have this bishop on b7
controlling c8 and a8 you have to you
want to have your knight
on a6 protecting against the rook coming
to b8 so knight to b4 is not a very
natural move i would say also at this
point he only had three minutes and 20
seconds yeah
for nine moves it's not an easy position
no pawn on c3 c2 never an easy position
there's always counter play right things
can always go wrong all right let's uh
wait what is happening i see a knight
jumping around knight is on d3 right i
mean he played knight d3 which is quite
honestly a logical move
probably will have to be followed for
white by knight to c1 right
i don't think i have a threat
but you also don't have a move
because if you don't play knight c1 i
actually don't know what you play the
rook is stuck the king is stuck and the
king is coming so knight c1 looks more
or less forced but
here i can even start considering to
play knight b2 we don't want to take
right
no no this is this should be bad we want
to keep the knights on the board yeah i
think you play knight b2 and then you
start harassing that pawn on a3
yeah black black is never losing this i
wonder how often you win it but you're
never losing it we're going to have to
wait and see all right let's take a look
at other games that have been finishing
up their time pressure i'll be mind you
mishra against your student raja harshit
let's see what is going on i still feel
that
black's position is on the brink of
collapse but he's done a good job not to
fall apart immediately that being said i
i just spotted the move f3
and uh if that rook
comes into the game
of course you don't want to exchange
this weak pawn on e4 but it's not an
exchange of pawns because if you take on
f3 i'm just going to mate you i assume
in this position
because the queen is coming to f7 so
that's not much of an alternative
uh and
f3 is a great move but
f3 just looks like it's a cruncher
and you know what the problem is for
harshit right now
white has all the time in the world to
find it because he just made time
control
yeah it's 41. it's also a very logical
move right the moment you find that
you're like oh yeah
you just need to open open the rook
against the king
the knight is very far away this king is
lacks defenders
this one looks pretty straight forward
winning
for the youngster who would pick up his
first point here for his first full
point here in the spring classic and uh
roger having a tough event tough events
going into zero out of three right now
yeah and
and trust me this is not a reflection of
his chest it's just a reflection of how
strong this is of a tournament
uh a very strong round robin indeed
we've seen great players start with zero
out of three in uh here at the saint
louis chess club well i can tell you
from my own experience uh one of the
last tournaments i think the penultimate
tournament that i played before my let's
say retirement before govind because i
haven't played in two and a half years
oh my goodness
are you inactive i am inactive right now
yes unfortunately i'm not even on the
romanian
list anymore but i played here at the st
louis chess club and i started i had the
worst tournament in my life i lost i
think 20 something points and i started
off with half out of five
it's just depressing yeah because in an
open tournament you're going to play
some weaker opposition whenever you lose
a game you're going to play a weaker
opposition here you're going to play
killers every single game you're going
to face killers and it's extremely
extremely difficult when you're
demotivated basically by losing so many
games
to put up a good performance and this is
exactly what we're seeing right now from
harshit as well yeah absolutely another
person that is not having the
determinant of his life seems to be
camille dragoon as
he is currently facing ray robson you
can see the material balance on the
board uh those two nights are happening
hop i'm not really sure how this
happened the bishops from white
disappeared
and i'm not slightly i'm very scared
about white's king because well they say
that a queen and a knight are very
attacking powerful combination but if
you add another knight to the mix well
that might just be game over currently
the knight on f6 is hitting the rook on
eight you have to do something about
that but also the move knight e4 is a
huge threat because the coordination of
this knight and this queen attacking g2
is only being defended by this queen on
the diagonal if that blocks the diagonal
form the queen that might be all she
wrote both sides have only one minute
left this game is over
he has played the move
rook a8 i assume that his idea is to
come down and defend like this but also
you start running into other problems
right knight e2 is kind of
that is game over that looks checkmate
that looks like a checkmate yes i don't
really see how to defend they can play
rook to a one give uh none of the rook
and that's it we resign before we do
that right these are professionals
no this is it just came over yeah
there's a checkmate in i don't know so a
few moves
well before the last move the computer's
best move was actually rook to h8 so you
can understand how bad yeah yes this is
completely dusty the actual checkmating
patterns for the knight and and i do
think knight to e2 is on the board and
that's just going to force resignation
well race starting with a strong two and
a half out of three but camille will be
falling down to half out of three again
not a reflection of the strength of the
polish player but more of reflection of
how strong this tournament is ray robson
a seasoned
veteran of the saint louis chescalera
played in u.s championships he's played
in many spring classics always a
fighting spirit uh always very well
prepared and absolutely chess
professional and he is showing his
strength here coming from a complicated
very double-edged position out playing
uh his rival and we are expecting
uh for the resignation and there you
have it
and robson moves on to two and a half
two and a half out of three a very good
start there for him but somebody else
with a great start even better than two
and a half out of three is three out of
three we have in the studio chris rapco
thank you alejandro yes we are here with
a very happy victor of the round there
is christopher repka he's who is perfect
mr perfect in this tournament right now
three out of three chris first of all
congratulations how do you feel right
now thank you i feel great it's not the
start i expected even though it's the
start i was hoping for
and especially today it was a from the
opening i didn't feel like i was doing
that great i didn't know what i was
doing actually and i was surprised how
fast i achieved an advantage let's uh
look through the game tell us
which do you think are the critical
moments well i think the critical moment
just one second i'm pulling it up
here
well the
okay the opening was
something that i was looking at but i
didn't look at it for a long while and i
didn't know the move dc4 so i wasn't
very happy right now but i was like okay
knight c3 like that's probably not a bad
move and now i didn't know what to do at
all so i
put my knight on the e5 but i didn't
like that the d4 square is just
so weak i wasn't sure how to evaluate it
and i saw the position
he played knight d4 i think that was all
good and now the critical moment arose
after he takes d4 h3 because i think
that he has two options here he can
either play bishop c8 or he can play
bishop f3 if he plays bishop f3 i think
the positional the position is
simplified maybe it's a tiny tiny bit
more pleasant for white because i have
more pawns on the with my kings and with
the opposite colored bishops i think
it's important to have
a good defense of your king and
he chose to play bishop takes f3 you
would take with i would assume queen
yeah queen takes bishop takes queen
takes knight xd5 would you take on d5 as
black or would you play a c6 right now i
was thought that c6 is not that good
because of knight f6 but maybe i'm wrong
but that was what i was looking at that
potentially i have rook d1 and i gained
a 10p and i thought maybe it's good
because after queen d6 i have e5 and
queen e5 runs into knight d7 fork oh
okay so put that on the board rook to d1
queen to d6 and now e5 crucial move full
of tricks
yeah that was my trick but he didn't go
into this
i think he should have maybe but bishop
c8 at first looked very dangerous
because i was looking at it and i'm like
i cannot take on d4 because c6 97 queen
e7 and despite the fact that i'm a pan
up he has just
the b2 is hanging and he is threatening
rook d8 he has two bishops well i think
you're just losing that extra pawn next
move yeah i might even be losing period
because i don't like this position
you have to go knight b3 or knight c2 no
that's just very scary very sad so i was
happy to have but i saw this
a few moves back and i saw the move
rookie one which i was happy with
and now i think it was another crucial
moment he played c6
which i think helped me because
yeah even the computer agrees with me
because knight f4 e5 e6 was my only plan
in the position
and i thought that instead of c6 if he
played c5
despite the fact that my knight is
pretty good on d5 i think he has two
bishops he has a nice pan on d4 and i
think it's just a position i am not sure
who's better i felt like black could
potentially be slightly better
all right so c6 helped you out a little
bit and i'm sure you were very happy
to see the move c5 played in this
position
i was happy to see the move a5 played
because uh i wasn't sure after e5 how to
even defend against e6
i didn't like his move a5 i think he
underestimated my attack there
so i think after c5 you play this move
e6 breaking through and i believe f5 was
a complete blunder what the the engine
was mentioning here was g5 g5 would you
consider this move i was looking at it i
was thinking that uh g5 usually is not
good
and i was looking at it it's a bit messy
but i thought that i should find a way
to be
at least slightly better maybe take on
f7 knight yes something simple like that
i just thought his king is so weak that
even though he has some things going for
him it's probably slightly better for me
and in the game after move five it
seemed like this clamp he just was
unable to get out of it of course pawn
on e6 is a monster the bishop on g2 a
monster the knight on f4 is great and
nothing is going right for the for the
black side
yeah i think what he was afraid of he
played f5 if you go a little bit back he
was worried he thought that he would
play queen d6 probably
but what i was planning after queen d6
was e takes f7 rook takes f7 knight d3
to threaten knight e5 and after knight
c6 i have knight d2
threatening both knight e4 and uh bishop
d5
that was my plan
it feels like black is just down
development 10 piece yeah yeah
which he kind of graciously gave with
the move a5 a5 c6 c5 yeah he lost too
many times so many times g4 bishop c8
yeah that's just too many i think maybe
not even that many like one too many
maybe two too many but that's all the
game takes and it felt that this after
this position you're just cruising
towards the victory
well chris a incredible start there
three out of three
as this game is over right now i believe
this one was a draw as well yep
alex managed to survive alex did manage
to survive that slightly unpleasant
position but he is a very resourceful
player
well chris congratulations uh three out
of three what are your ambitions right
now for the tournament i'm just gonna
go get some dinner and play it game game
by game i realized that it's such a long
tournament with very good players and
i'm just grateful for to be in the
position i'm in and yeah we'll see what
i make out of it well congratulations
and we're looking forward to see you in
the next round thank you
absolutely so we do have some results
coming in uh of course the big one on
group a is ray robson defeating camille
dragon let's take a quick look at
jeffrey shanks
position
i'm not really sure how they got here
this might still be hopeless for young
jeffrey it seems like he has lost a pawn
that is not surprising what is
surprising that he only lost upon
but
after the move knight e3 we left it off
here h3 he did not find the move um
queen g1 which is just an incredible
move rook a1
bishop f1 and i think this is a nice
solution queen f1 check takes takes rook
d3 takes on g3
and he has
not only one a pawn but probably the
best one pawn you can win the g pawn and
the knight is still on h4 yeah the
knight still on h4 hasn't gone anywhere
that's incredible the spot on d6 should
fall at some point
uh i was wondering why you can't play f5
but okay six oh okay six you you just
lose the knight the knight but f5 looks
pretty compelling all right i assume
there's a reason ah f5 maybe he was
concerned about
no no but that's that's an idea yeah
yeah i don't believe in it all right so
we got this position and
it still looks pretty hopeless to me the
spawn on d6 is a little too fur further
advanced
uh i feel like i'm just gonna go king e6
and somehow collect it
yeah just looks winning right and any
time we change the rooks it's going to
be game over yeah because we know uh
knight uh knight and pawn end games
usually resemble just pawn end games and
pondering games with the pawn down and
you're generally lost yeah but it's not
even going to be one pawn down there's
gonna be two pawns down yeah yeah this
one looks like aram is doing a great job
absolutely fantastic performance here by
the webster student uh let's take a look
at our students uh misha antipov and
dario sphere the knight did land on f6
okay what i am wondering is what route
did this rook take
but okay you landed the night on
f6 but you lost the pawn in the process
what happened here all right let me go
back i am very confused about all these
things
all right so he did play the king g6 we
left it off here knight g4 we considered
this
we thought h5 was fine but maybe rook
knight takes e3 is also a move that
makes a lot of sense
now it takes e3
okay h5 so to us do not allow the knight
back we're thinking about g4 around here
but it seems like he never played it
and
h4 was played still g4 looks
kind of tempting i really don't know
knight g4 he played instead it actually
released the lock on this rook
on f3 and allowed it to transfer to the
king side to the queen side sorry and
here you are actually faced with a
double attack it's not just that i'm
doing
the obvious by attacking the pawn on b5
but also this rook is threatening yeah
to even more crunchy
take all the pawns on the
of third you still have some sort of
compensation right that's right you do
but at this moment i feel that we went
from a more or less equal position to
black being the one playing for a win
but we can ask the
opinion of a stronger player than us who
is joining us in the studio we have ray
robson with an incredible start two and
a half out of three uh despite starting
with two of those three games being with
black uh ray how does it feel
oh yeah it feels pretty good i
i mean
i don't know today's game was pretty
complicated i'm not really sure what to
think about it um i think it was it
started off quite slow with the joko
piano but after that it just exploded
yeah i mean i think the italian isn't
really i mean it's kind of a slow line
no it's very complicated not anymore
these days there's tons of theory so i
actually played an i think a novelty
um
in the opening with d5
let me get to that point
about the way back here
yeah d5 in this position yeah because
already knight d7 is a little bit
unusual and normally the idea would be
to play with f5 if you're going to move
the knight to d7
i have to ask you one question how do
you keep all the italians straight
how do you not confuse one with the
other yeah i'm not sure i mean i get
confused also i guess let's say if
you're black i guess you just try to
choose like one sort of setup for a
particular game and just look at all the
lines
in that variation if you're white
you you probably need to remember a lot
more because black can do so many
different things so
it's a difficult opening
difficult opening to prepare um
but yeah i mean what he did was
interesting take 693
all very natural
i played f5 and then he went d4
and
after e4 i spent a lot of time because i
thought e4 he was going to play c4
which is like very sharp
um so i spent
i used up all my time advantage thinking
about this and then a bishop f7 right
you spent all your time yeah yeah bishop
f7 d5 um
one idea was knight e5 knight takes e5
knight takes bishop c5
c5 here so he traps my rook but i should
have some play and i can come to d3
queen can come to g5 with some threats
it's very complicated that's what i was
thinking about but instead he just
played knight h2 immediately and so i
felt really dumb because i would never
have i would have moved instantly if i
knew he was going to play that h2
but yeah this position is still very
unclear like it's
i can play f4 which looks very tempting
um looks like i have a big attack but
after he just moves the bishop back
i don't know how to continue yeah bishop
not sure which one but one of the
squares
then e4 is weakened now um because yeah
because my f pawns move so c4 is an idea
always and his knight now has a square
on g4 in the future
um so it's not clear so instead i kind
of played much more slowly and then the
game was um
yeah just a lot of maneuvering but it
felt like he was putting some practical
pressure on me i didn't think my
position was like bad but
he was putting some practical pressure
and then much later in the game um maybe
around move
30.
he made a move like queen
or was a queen b6 which was very
very unexpected
this is a very complicated game but yeah
oh queen b6 here yeah i mean he just
moved his queen all the way away from
like his king my last move was rookie
eight so it's clear i have some ideas to
maybe play e3 right and finally get some
sort of direct play going
instead of queen b6 i was kind of
concerned about d5
c takes d5 and now very interesting move
c5 maybe
if i don't take then he has a pass pawn
so if i take bishop takes f6 gf6 queen
f6
rookie 7 looks the most logical then
eight
rookie eight rook takes bishop takes
queen takes f5 it's equal material you
would think it's um completely fine for
black but somehow is knights activating
i have some weaknesses and there's some
concrete lines like let's say queen d6
knight g4 king g7 looks like
everything's secure but he has queen h5
he hits h6 and my knight's pin to the
bishop
and if queen f4 then d5 hangs it's very
unfortunate i
i couldn't find like a easy defense here
so i wasn't sure what i was going to do
if he if he went for that um instead
queen b6 we were both now low on time
and yeah then i just went for the attack
and
i'm not sure what if we played the best
moves but in general it seemed like the
game completely shifted in my direction
at this this point queen d8 and now yeah
bishop e8 maybe he kind of
underestimated this
he doesn't really have any threats and
i'm threatening the bishop and the
knight with the rook
and seems like yeah i'm just winning
material by force here yeah this is
collapsing and of course after yeah this
is not going to hold the two pieces are
too powerful
oh that nice you it seems like you
outplayed your opponent in that
complication
wasn't able to keep pace
yeah
i can show one line at the end very end
of the game the last move
that he made so here
so i'm threatening the rook i'm
threatening knight e4 actually to block
his queen from defending g2 so he has to
hope for some miracle perpetual ideas so
rookie 7 i thought was the best
try and then if 94 maybe he can sack i
mean it probably doesn't work rook g7
but he can try it so instead i i thought
the most precise was knight
six or knight three to d5
six to d5 knight six to d5 yeah and now
for g7
king g7 queen d7 uh king f6
queen check somewhere king f7 and then i
block on e7 with the knight and
everything's defended so i thought that
was a clean win
great back to back victories with the
black pieces the second one how do you
feel uh
at this point and who do you have
tomorrow
yeah so my previous game i was just
white so it wasn't
back to back with black but yeah my next
game i think i'm white against jeffrey
white again jeffrey that's a big matchup
wish you good luck and we'll see you in
the next rounds thanks
absolutely speaking of jeffrey shawn
let's take a look at how he is trying to
survive here against aram hakobian it
doesn't seem that
he will be able to do so it seems like
the young player from western highly
motivated player is going to take this
one home i like the move rook d4 you can
imagine that this knight on e8 yes it's
holding to that pawn on d6 but
it's not gonna stay there forever right
this knight on e8 will be expelled at
some point you can even try to exchange
it sometimes with simply knight f6
uh you cannot possibly go into any kind
of knight end game
so i expect maybe rook e3 but
this looks
very bad for
the texas player
let's go around
the horn on the games that we have
remaining
this one is a particularly interesting
one aram
against christopher u
even material for the moment and even
after rogue b3 actually
black has a threat actually how did this
happen it doesn't feel
that this went white's way
we left it over here we'd like takes and
rook d3
it takes sticks we liked all of this i
thought we are okay five bishop d7
i don't know about the move rook e5 i
don't know what this move does
i was thinking we're going to play g3 f4
and fix this weakness and also start
thinking about rook a6 type checkmates i
think he just wants to transfer the rook
on the other side and prepare and move
c5 and say that you cannot go king to f4
because i have a look to e7 so that's a
threat right rookie 7 is
kind of a threat but
the problem is that if you go for rookie
7 now i have king f6
right so that doesn't do much h4 was a
key move stopping me from going g3 f4
very nice move and he's activated the
rook and it just feels like this went
from a um
to result game to a three result game
i don't like this king on h3
no does he have anything concrete
it doesn't seem like it
no it doesn't seem like all right
maybe just something along the lines of
uh well maybe c6 at this point and just
try to
break even
yeah but that's a tough that's a top
psychological decision right you could
play c6 and just say take my bishop i'll
take yours i'm going to not be in any
control yeah right but
i mean you're trying to play for a win
right you've been uh you've been ahead
for so long we're just going to cheat
him use the engine for a little bit yeah
the engine says c6 play loud is actually
the best move
c6 rook d5
it seems like the position actually has
balance this balance is actually nothing
um i'll be mind you mishra against right
he did did he play the move f3 he did uh
queen e5 f3 king g8 okay knight g4 first
yeah i mean i could even take on h6 if i
felt like it but this one is not looking
great for
[ __ ] it seems like probably abimanu will
score a victory i think he just resigns
here queen e7 oh we do seven night two
h6 because this is a threat picking up
not one but two pawns knight six has the
biggest three g7 yeah but that picks up
two points right here yeah you pick this
guy you pick this guy maybe you pick
this that's a lot of uh that's a lot of
pawns that's too many pawns and it's not
like his kingdom animating attack
the poor guy man he has zero out of
three oh man
i have a rough night tonight yeah titus
armavicious uh
i still think he's the one trying to
hold on
in this end game against uh jj ali
morandi
but uh
you would expect the player of his
caliber to hold on to it though
i don't expect white to lose this one
yes we deny to on c1 and the rook
potentially entering the fray if you
take with the bishop then yeah it does
feel like you will have enough
compensation for equality yeah yeah
that's why that's right and we're going
to let uh antipov andarish fight it out
we actually have no updates in that
position after the move h4 let's take a
look at what the uh results of today
have been so far
uh we have three of them ready for you
in group a in group a we have hans
niemann who uh finished quite quickly
against sam savion with a draw didn't
manage to put a lot of pressure as white
alex lenderman survived against ilya
nishnik kamil dragoon unfortunately
succumbed under the pressure of the
silent assassin ray
ray robson and mikhail antipov against
darius and jeffrey sean against the ram
jacobian still pending
absolutely and in group b we have
uh the following results chris repka
moves on to three out of three
absolutely amazing tournament for him so
far uh defeating his
uh
defeating samahanin uh also mario the
body and robert nagaski has played the
point and as we still have three
remaining games but i think the clearest
result uh from these will be absolutely
ami manumisra defeating raja hershey we
expect that resignation at any moment
well that was a fun round alejandro
absolutely
join us tomorrow we will be back at the
same time 3 30 p.m central time that's
when the show starts the games however
start at 1 p.m central time so plan your
schedules accordingly and we'll see you
tomorrow see you tomorrow don't uh miss
us and remember the game started one but
we'll be here at 3 30 just to recap what
has happened see you tomorrow see you
guys
do
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the
saint louis chess club any reproduction
or distribution of this content without
the express written consent of the st
louis chess club is prohibited